for fps junkies such as myself
there's
pretty much nothing more important
than sensitivity it's the number one
command that gets spammed in your
favorite streamers chat each and every
waking moment hell they don't even need
to be live on twitch to have someone pop
in and start asking but as i'm sure many
of you are aware there are essentially
two schools of fps player there are
those who play with high sense and those
who play with low sense some high
sensitivity superstars have made a name
for themselves because of their freakish
flicks and snappy spray downs and simple
oh looking to get him while he runs oh
holy [ __ ] yeah it wasn't that fast
while others have managed to crack the
code of popping heads with some of the
lowest sensitivities in esports this is
where reynolds are born this is where
arenas are bred one more yep now the
duelists are starting to come through
on this week's episode we are taking a
look at some of the greatest players
ever to brandish a low sense in esports
why do they do it how do they do it and
are they sort of holding themselves back
by using such a sluggish sensitivity
okay so before we start talking about
sensitivities and cs and all that cool
stuff we got to talk really quick about
valorent more specifically the vct watch
parties that liz has been hosting and
will continue to host this weekend on
our twitch channel so if you're at all
interested be sure to check out
twitch.tv slash the score esports to
watch liz curse people doesn't lose
so if you are a tactical fps player then
there's a very good chance that either
now or sometime in the past you have
gravitated towards a so-called low
sensitivity especially when you are sort
of learning the ins and outs of the
genre part of the reason for this is
that such genre of shooter typically
requires far less vertical movement than
say arena shooters or battle royales try
playing fortnight with the low sens and
chances are you're going to get your
[ __ ] kicked in by a 12 year old snorting
a tide pod well lower sense is just
easier to control and attack fps is
right we're not playing battle royales
this is an apex this is in fortnite
we're no one's cranking the 90. like
this is like if you have good game sense
right they can only come out of this one
choke so if you just have the most
control
for like you know
this specific kind of like field right
where they're just like within like this
slim view they show up on your screen
here that you have the most control
there and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
all right let's take this out of the
context of tack shooters for a change
because as much as dimitri loves to wax
philosophical about counter-strike there
are in fact other games since ethos was
kind enough to mention a game that i
actually play let's chat about apex
while on the surface apex and cs are
both first person shooters
the actual shooting couldn't be more
different between the two and they make
a great example for different ways that
you can harness your sensitivity as a
tool where cs gunfights are generally
slow and methodical in apex they're fast
and frantic you're often fighting
multiple people or even multiple teams
of legends who are sprinting flying
portaling or zip lining through the
fight thanks to the speed of movement
and the longer time to kill you're
generally rewarded more for your ability
to track with your aim rather than
simply flicking and hitting that initial
shot faster thanks to these differences
you see a markedly higher average edpi
among apex pro players when compared to
cs and valorem roughly
1169 according to the data on
prosettings.net between all of that and
the entire other video we did on
sensitivity not to mention mouse
acceleration i think it's pretty fair to
say that you can often be best served by
a different sense in different games
but i want to take this idea one step
further and suggest that playing
different roles even in the same game
could also warrant a sensitivity shift
since i've been playing a lot of hockey
recently allow me a sports metaphor to
illustrate my point everyone on the ice
has a stick but they will vary from
player to player the length curve of the
blade flexibility angle between the
shaft and blade are all variables a
player can choose to best fit their
position and style of play while i
certainly don't think it's a necessity
being open to changing your sensitivity
could make you a much more versatile
player between different games and
different roles up to a certain point
you could actually find some real
benefit experimenting with different
sensitivities when you take on different
roles or characters for your team but
that qualifier up to a certain point is
also important here you're bound to lose
any of those potential benefits if
you're just wildly shifting your
sensitivity every round moving in small
steps from an established comfortable
base is also a critical piece of the
puzzle most of us aren't pro players
spending almost all of our time
mastering a single game so as you jump
from game to game or even roll to roll
you shouldn't feel chained to your
sensitivity and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
now before you all go ahead and start
hemorrhaging dpi there is a very
simple practical question that you need
to ask yourself
and that is
how much desk space do you have you see
playing on a low sensitivity does
raise certain spatial limitations if
your desk or mouse pad is too small then
you might find yourself lifting your
mouse a little too often and thus losing
control of your movements what license
plate suffer from is when they peek
somewhere they're not expecting off
their screen right those big flicks that
take a long time to travel they might
not even have might not even have enough
mouse pad you know
depending on how low their sense is and
yet in spite of these admittedly
annoying spatial constraints the vast
majority of attack fps players still
default to a lower sensitivity and
that's because with some good crosshair
placement and just decent game sense
even an average player can see some
solid results by simply holding an angle
at head level and clicking on your
opponent's head as they step into your
view you can eliminate the need to flick
now i say that but it's pretty natural
to wonder why anyone would even want to
use a low dpi when there are aimbots out
there doing crazy [ __ ] like this with
ridiculously high adpis you're looking
primed for 12 unless someone can
absolutely pop off is it time for asuna
does he get a timing here under android
juan's trying to push he's the weapon
finally kill austin up for three would
have to be an ace it's information finds
the fourth knows where the last player
is paige trying to push him out but can
he actually find the kill in time blast
back over thank you
will use this to get at least halfway in
the defusal shanks on the opposite
picture in picture oh my god
you see at first glance playing with
high sensitivity
sort of just
looks better players like asuna are
known for their twitchy aim and some of
their ridiculous highlights might not
have ever been possible had they not
been playing on a high sense just like
we mentioned in our episode on mouse
sensitivity last year high sense players
are often wrist aimers who can easily
whip their crosshair around in game the
higher your edpi the less you have to
move your mouse around your mouse pad in
order to click heads and
it makes sense especially for those of
you who might have limited desk space if
you simply can't swing your arm around
in giant strides or want that sudden
control that wrist aiming offers you
might feel forced to use a higher
sensitivity and it's not necessarily a
bad thing for some of the world's best
aimers these physical limitations have
actually helped define their playstyle
is he really gonna take this fight again
it's creek versus zorp and precise as
always
it was six in a row
[Music]
jumps into the jaws and what he's so
damn hungry here
he's had his dinner
look at the shots coming through this
guy is one of the world's fastest
snipers unbelievable so good and look at
him go another amazing shot the high
sensitivity prevails but just like there
are players who are known for their
wrist shattering flicks there are also
those who are known to have mastered the
art of arm aiming their pixel perfect
crosshair placement allows them to hold
angles and pop heads as enemies just
walk into their waiting arms 30 seconds
nico looking to activate takes to all
three
for most players who are nude attack fps
it's often recommended to start off on
lower sensitivity so as to think
specifically about crosshair placement
eliminating the need to flick typically
helps with consistency since it quite
literally forces you to think about the
best place to put your crosshair it's
really hard to be consistent on high
sense there's just some days where
you know you might hit everything and
it'll look super flashy because you have
this like ridiculous sensitivity but
uh this is just gonna be days where you
just can't hit those pixels as
consistently and then those are the days
that are gonna really stick out for you
because you know you're just getting
bodied by people holding angles and you
can't do anything about it and in the
world of counter-strike in particular
there are a ton of competitors who are
known for boasting some
pretty freaking low edpies nico and
twists for example are some of the
greatest players ever to touch the game
and they play on 604 and 560 edpi
respectively and this might just be one
of the reasons that they've been able to
remain so damn consistent over their
careers they're considered some of the
best riflers and deaglers in the entire
world hell twists just won a [ __ ]
major
it's up to carrick and broke he does hit
the shot and carrick good for the
headshot now running out of options
[Applause]
former kinguin vertice pro and evil
geniuses rifler mihu is known for taking
low sends a step further boasting an
absurdly low edpi of
376. this dude must have the widest
[ __ ] desk in the world
but it doesn't stop him from clapping
cheeks uh-oh no not like this
oh god he's out there he's exposed
they're toying with him but me who is
absolutely perfect now as i'm sure you
all remember when valerian came out
everyone was quick to compare it to
counter-strike it was a new tack fps
with very similar gun mechanics and many
of the cs go pros who switched games
brought their same sensitivities over to
valorant and just converted them but
fallen isn't the same game at all in
fact many pros have found themselves
raising their sensitivities to
compensate for all of the agent
abilities good luck shooting the endless
flying utility [ __ ] when a jet or
raise or whatever jumps over your head
while you're playing on low sense
you'll just end up
swinging your mouse off your desk but
that said there is one player who
continues to play valorant on a very low
sensitivity and that anomaly is the
chaos boy himself
leaf they're better
they've just been incredible
that was us to meet up here always go
over it again ferrari swinging and leaf
rips his head off
one man
it was going in favor of cryo
i'm not sure it will be at the end of
this
leaf is our monster right now his knives
back again it's the first map too where
we've been able to see this jet
head-to-head leaf is cloud nine's golden
boy he's one of the most cracked
duelists in north american valorant and
you can pretty much always count on
seeing some form of highlight from him
basically after every c9 match but what
makes leaf so special is the fact that
he plays with an in-game sense of
.185 at 800 dpi which makes his valerant
edpi just 148.
of course since valorent's sensitivity
slider isn't actually one-to-one and
thus the so-called edpis listed on sites
like pro settings don't actually mean
anything we multiply by 3.18 convert it
to an actual one-to-one sensitivity
multiplier and that gives us a cogent
value of about 470 edpi this dude is
basically doing an upper body workout
every time he queues into deathmatch
just to put this in perspective the
average edpi of a valorant competitor is
about
898 according to prosettings.net well no
pro settings has it listed as 280 but
again that doesn't mean anything okay
just to make sure that this doesn't all
sound like dimitri being his usual cs
elitist self i do want to back him up on
this one we talked about edpi in our
previous mouse sensitivity episode but
pro settings.net will calculate this
stat by multiplying your mouse dpi by
the sensitivity value in game the
problem one sensitivity and counter
strike is not the same as one
sensitivity in valorem so while they
call both these numbers edpi
you can't compare one with the other in
any meaningful way for a quick example
one sensitivity on 800 dpi and
counter-strike gives you your full 800
effective dpi of sensitivity but those
same settings in valorem would be the
equivalent of roughly 2
545 effective dpi this is why we need to
convert each game to a one-to-one
sensitivity scale before we calculate
the edpi one other metric that people
often use when comparing between games
is centimeters per 360. so anytime we
had edpi values up on screen i threw up
the corresponding centimeters per 360 so
that we could all be on the same page
long story short edpi isn't just dpi
multiplied by sensitivity
anyway i'll let dimitri get back to
talking about leaf pretty much half as
slow as the average valorett pro leaf
sensitivity is one of the lowest you
will ever see in the esport
which might actually be why he's been
able to remain so damn consistent but
what's particularly impressive is the
fact that he plays these in-your-face
duelist agents like jet and reyes
many entry fraggers tend to play on a
slightly higher sensitivity because
their job is to clear angles as rapidly
as possible and make space for their
team flashes to get in they're gonna
have to win these gunfights and then
they'll have so many problems on their
hands and just no solutions tping away
it's fast but not fast enough to leave
watching him play it's like i didn't
expect him to be on low sense to be
honest right but he his game sense is
just that good and he always has a plan
for
you know if this this or this happens
this is what i'm gonna do that
he doesn't need to
kind of be more flexible with his aim
and his crosshair on his sensitivity
because he already has all these planned
out he already he's already expecting
these nine other different things and
that's what makes leaf such a great
player of course now that chamber has
effectively ruined the [ __ ] game leaf
has been playing the french opera more
and more and you could argue that it
actually suits his sensitivity even more
than duelists like jet and reyes but
since the recent chamber nerfs are yet
to hit pro play at the time of writing
we'll just have to wait and see if
duelist mains like leif return to
playing jet and potentially give back
the sentinel role to one of their
teammates but let's get back to the
final question that we posed at the four
which is
are players like leaf or twists sort of
nerfing themselves by playing at such a
low sensitivity cs go riflers in
particular tend to gravitate towards a
lower sensitivity overall with an
average edpi of 854
while offers have an average edpi of
1096 according to prosettings.net so
although guys like twists and leaf do
play on a much lower sensitivity than
the average rifler
i think it's fair to say that it suits
their role and they're not putting
themselves at too much of a disadvantage
twists was considered to be one of the
most unstoppable aimers in cs during
liquid's grand slam run in 2019 and he
continued to boast the highest headshots
per round of any pro player throughout
all of 2020 and 2021 in spite of his
absurdly low sense like lily like anyone
can out aim somebody
especially like everyone like top five
i'm gonna put myself though i don't care
his sensitivity may be low in comparison
to others but there isn't one
sensitivity that trumps all as much as
we'd all like to just plug in our
favorite pro settings and frag out
that's not how it works it takes time to
find your own godsense that magic number
is different for everyone and the time
that it takes to find it varies not only
from player to player but
game to game i play siege for instance
at 7 7 58 so about 728 e dpi and
whenever people watch my pov they think
my sensitivity is at least twice as high
as it actually is just because you're on
low sense doesn't mean you can't be
flicky and frantic and in control
what's really weird is that i actually
prefer to play siege on low sends and
counter-strike on high sense if it
weren't for compatibility issues i.e
muscle memory i'd pretty much only ever
play cs go at what i have dubbed the
shroud sends 2.7 at 400 which is about
1080 edpi
since for whatever reason it feels best
for me who knows maybe it's because i'm
a chad who plays native
[Music]
speaking of resolution
that's actually one of the things that
allows for turrets like nico and twists
to one tap fools with such precision
the fact that they play on 4-3 stretched
sure their sensitivities are low as [ __ ]
but because their povs are stretched out
they can basically tunnel vision on
whatever the hell is actually on it they
may not be able to see a lot or 180 on a
dime but if you do happen to be
unfortunate enough to end up on these
dude's screens you are just [ __ ] dead
nico he's not going to respect that
looks to push over top
we've got nitro still 8 hp because oh
what
that's so sick
nico just gonna rock their world b site
is gone
oh and the retake is nothing it is
nothing
in the face of nico
but that's what works for them just like
something else might work for you low
sense is reliable but
it isn't for everyone
nothing is unfortunately sensitivity is
just
finicky like that there's multiple
sensitivities that are good there's tons
that'll work for different people and i
hate to break it to you it's going to
take a lot of trial and error
individually for you to find the perfect
cs go sense for yourself i think it just
depends on the player really at the end
of the day like i mean if you're used to
it you're going to be used to it but i
think switching your sense every after
every game or whatever in the middle of
the game you're definitely going to be
inconsistent because all that muscle
memory that you built up won't be there
so maybe it's time for some of you to
try something new who knows maybe low
sense is exactly what you need to start
ranking up
it can take time to find that one
special sensitivity but
trust me the moment you do
is magical
that's what it is bro they just take one
number they take another number they
slap them together and then the
butterfly meme is this edpi
it's infuriating
[Music]
get rid of part of you that cringes
keep the part of you
that loves the cringe